in the west valley now have a spot to  sharpen their skills thanks to a slam  dunk donation from basketball legend and  las vegas resident shaquille o'neal his  foundation along with icy hot gave 200  thousand dollars to renovate the courts  at doolittle complex  some people call it giving back i call  it doing what you're supposed to do  it was dr j who was nice to me  it was magic johnson he was nice to me  so  even though these kids look at me  a superstar i want to be the guy that  if he did it we can do it  he is just the best well he tells us he  hopes this will give young athletes who  come from a similar background as him  the chance to do more